bonsoir voici les titres de l'actualité
de ce jeudi 12 octobre un état de guerre
entre israël et les palestiniens trois
militaires israéliens lynché à mort par
des palestiniens à ramallah aussitôt
israël riposte plusieurs raids
israéliens ont été menées sur ramallah
et les sites abritant la direction
l'autorité palestinienne à son tour le
hamas islamique menace les etats-unis la
france lance des appels pour sauver la
paix et arrêter cet engrenage
très haute surveillance policière à
biarritz pour le sommet de l'union
européenne on craint les réactions des
séparatistes basques espagnols de letea
dès le 1er décembre prochain ce sera la
fin des fiches d'état civil et des
justificatifs de domicile premières
mesures pour simplifier la vie des
citoyens
l'exclusion sans doute ce soir pour jean
tiberi du rpr ce sera fait ce soir le
prix nobel de littérature décerné à un
écrivain naturalisé français en écrivain
de langue chinoise gao xingjian
un véritable état de guerre 10h dans les
titres au proche-orient tout a commencé
ce matin ramallah où une foule furieuse
de jeunes palestiniens envahi un
commissariat de police s'est emparé de
militaires israéliens ce fut un lynchage
terrible trois militaires sont morts un
autre grièvement blessé la réponse
d'israël fut quasi immédiate une série
de raids aériens il y portait sur un
malin mais aussi à gaza autour du
quartier général de yasser arafat récit
de charles enderlin avec des images
insupportables de ce lynchage
trésor c'est le drame quatre réservistes
israéliens en civil se sont trompés de
chemin ils viennent d'être arrêtés à
barrage palestinien d'où ils ont été
conduits dans ce poste de police devant
une foule ça semble dans la rue
avoisinante
la voiture des israéliens est incendiée
les jeunes deviennent de plus en plus
violents ils sont persuadés qu'il s'agit
de soldats appartenant à une unité
spéciale la foule force l'entrée du
commissariat c'est le lynchage le corps
d'une victime est lancée par la fenêtre
trois soldats sont assassinés le
quatrième serait toujours en vie à
ramallah
l'alerté donnée en israël des chars sont
déployés pour boucler toutes les villes
palestiniennes à ramallah les civils
s'enferme chez eux la riposte est
inévitable les rues sont désertes
voici l'entrée nord de la ville où
depuis treize jours des jeunes venaient
affronté l'armée israélienne
et vers 15 heures les premières
roquettes tirées par les hélicoptères
d'assaut cobra explosent sur le poste de
police
il n'y a que deux blessés légers l'armée
israélienne avait conseillé à l'autorité
autonome d'évacuer ses locaux c'est là
qu'elle mit à nouveau la foule
s'assemblent et cris allahu akbar dieu
est grand
marwan barghouti le chef du fatah en
cisjordanie vient aux nouvelles personne
ici dit il n'a peur des hélicoptères
israéliens des roquettes israéliennes
tout le monde sait que le président
arafat exprimé ses regrets pour la mort
des soldats un membre de la sécurité
palestinienne intervient c'est la guerre
dit il on m'a tiré en va tirer ball awad
le chef de la force 17 les gardes
prétoriennes de yasser arafat
israël dit il utilise des avions mais ce
ne sont que des feux d'artifice
nous sommes unis nous n'avons pas peur
nous battrons pour notre sion pas d'une
position palestinienne
attaqué par les hélicoptères à boulez à
chef de la police palestinienne affirme
que 17 de ses hommes ont été blessés par
la foule en tentant de protéger les
soldats israéliens n'ont rien pu faire
dit il c'était notre honneur de les
garder les selon l'armée israélienne des
policiers palestiniens ont participé ou
la jalle
ans charles enderlin l'attaquant riposte
israélienne est officiellement annoncée
comme terminée mais est ce la fin de cet
état de guerre
apparemment non en tout cas les
israéliens tant à l'heure actuelle de
calmer le jeu ils affirment qu'ils ont
fait tout pour qu'il y ait le moins
possible de perte du côté palestinien
effectivement l'autorité a été averti
des commissariats de police attaqués
avaient été évacués auparavant israël
annonce aux palestiniens attention c'est
une attaque symbolique si vous riposté
via une escale de votre part il y aura
également une escalade chez nous lors
grenages hélas le proche-orient de bord
du gouffre merci charles à gaza en
territoire palestinien les représailles
de l'armée isrélienne auraient fait de
nombreux blessés la radio voix de la
palestine a cessé d'émettre depuis
ramallah après avoir été touché par des
missiles yasser arafat considère ce soir
c'est raide comme une guerre les forces
palestiniennes ont été placées en état
d'urgence et le mouvement de résistance
islamique hamas menacé israël de payer
le prix fort la plupart des détenus du
hamas avait été relâché de la prison
centrale à gaza dans le courant de la
journée reportage de nos envoyés
spéciaux à gaza l'installeront gilles
jacquier et talal abou rahmeh
panique générale dans les rues de gaza
il ya le tir ils viennent de tirer nous
hurle ses hommes
les femmes et les enfants se ruent vers
les abris
les policiers semblent perdus cherche
une cible
vous avez vu les deux hélicoptères ils
ont lâché des roquettes vous avez vu
ils sont toujours là dans le ciel au
dessus du quartier général d'arafat
les forces palestiniennes cours dans
cette direction la rumeur sens c'est
bien le qg du chef qui a été visée
les russes sont vides et ne circulent
plus que des taxis à feu les des
véhicules de police et des ambulances en
trombe sirènes hurlantes les civils sont
maintenant dans les abris un policier
temps de les rassurer
restez calme n'ayez pas peur leur dit il
dort un homme reste résignée ou
fataliste
les gens comme moi
à quoi bon je n'ai pas d'autre endroit
où aller que chez moi
les hélicoptères c'est toujours dans
ciels
nouvelle salle la direction semble
clairement le port à 500 mètres du
bureau de rafah là un homme a dû
c'est là qu'ils ont tiré le poste de la
marine
le poste de marine le voici un bateau a
été coulé effectivement le poste lui
même a été touché il y à 16 blessés dont
quatre militaires
la police évacue les badauds venus aux
nouvelles
car la bataille n'est peut-être pas
terminée
au large à moins d'un kilomètre des
vedettes et des barges de débarquement
israélienne avec des hommes à bord on
croit à une menace du débarquement
ce ne sont pas assez kalachnikov qui les
dissuade rond et le fait est là les
barges resteront pas là
la nuit tombée yasser arafat pas rendre
visite aux blessés de cette journée de
folie à gaza
journée de guerre contre le peuple
palestinien at il déclaré
première journée de guerre depuis les
accords d'oslo 1993
des accords qui semble ce soir bien mal
en point
alors sitôt connue ce lynchage de
soldats israéliens la population
israélienne déterrait était en état de
choc le gouvernement d'ehud barak se
réunissent en urgence mais à jérusalem
comme dans d'autres villes de
cisjordanie les réactions ont été très
vives voyez le reportage claude samper
avec mauss jaermann
ils ont l'oeil rivé sur les écrans kelly
show qu à mère en colère
regardez regardez ce qu'ils ont fait à
nos soldats bien sûr ce soir on est tous
inquiets
ils ont fait une grande erreur
maintenant la coupe est pleine les gens
ne peuvent plus riches gagnent
maintenant il faut réagir que pensez
vous de la réaction du gouvernement
israélien je crois que la réponse n'est
pas assez forte ils auraient dû mettre
une bombe une énorme bombe à ramallah
après ce qu'ils ont fait on aurait dû
tous les bombarder
dans la rue parfois les gens s'arrêtent
spontanément devant nous pour réagir
avec des arabes et nous avons de très
bonnes relations mais je pense qu'il ya
quelque chose de brisé je suis très très
triste la situation est heureusement car
elle réagit c'est ce qu'on attend de
nous
la réponse est suffisante
j'espèrerais ça dépendra des
palestiniens
dans tous les cafés les magasins même
parfois les salons de coiffure les
israéliens sont à l'écouté des dernières
nouvelles
arafat n'a pas le contrôle de ses
troupes dans la rue maintenant il n'y a
plus de solution nous on ne veut pas la
violence
il faut réagir
quelques automobilistes s'arrêtent
également brahim il est temps de faire
la guerre on n'a aucune raison d'être
effrayé par le monde arabe on est fort
on est plus fort recul et ça notre
premier ministre commence à le
comprendre alors que la nuit tombe sur
jérusalem les israéliens suivez toujours
minute par minute l'évolution de la
situation
voilà pour les réactions des israéliens
la nuit tombée alain de chalvron vous
êtes à gaza ce soir quel est l'état
d'esprit à gaza va écouter la tension
est très très forte vous pouvez
l'imaginer il y aurait nous attendent il
est en ce moment même des combats très
sérieux à erez c'est à dire la frontière
entre israël et la bande de gaza une
dizaine de kilomètres d'ici là aussi des
manifestations de soutien à yasser
arafat oui les gens sont mobilisés dans
une atmosphère de combativité la
télévision palestinienne repasse en
boucle des images des combats de ces
derniers jours des images souvent atroce
et les gens effectivement ont montré
qu'ils n'avaient pas peur de mourir nous
libérons notre terre avec no more nous
disait tout à l'heure un responsable du
jihad islamique
et effectivement ce sont des paroles qui
font peur qu'ils sont très dures mais
qui reflète assez largement le sentiment
ici oui mobilisation les gens sont prêts
à accueillir les les israéliens s'il le
faut avec simplement leur poitrine à
faire un bain de sang à 26 ans offert en
quelque sorte à l'opinion publique
internationale les gens en ont assez les
conditions de vie dans cette bande de
gaza qui est tout petit qui est
surpeuplée avec un mini personnes si on
dérive les gens la pression nous ne pas
avoir grand chose à perdre alors
distille si israël veut la guerre est
bien qu'il l'ait merci alain cette
extrême violence et ses actes de guerre
ont repris alors que les efforts
diplomatiques internationaux semblent s
accompagné d'une relative accalmie kofi
annan secrétaire général de l'onu a
multiplié les appels aujourd'hui à la
cessation des violences tout comme les
américains ou encore le roi de jordanie
et le président égyptien commentaires
jean-marc il ose
la recherche de la paix est incompatible
avec la violence perpétrée par arafat et
qu'il continue à déclencher vient
d'accuser à l'instant shlomo ben-ami
ministre israélien des affaires
étrangères ce matin le gouvernement
israélien avait qualifié de très grave
le lynchage des deux réservistes
israéliens
de leur côté à amman le roi abdallah de
jordanie et le président égyptien
moubarak appelle israël à cesser les
actes de violence contre les
palestiniens et rejette le langage de la
violence et de la menace qui compromet
les espoirs de paix dans la région
de beyrouth un appel pressant à la
retenue lancé aux deux parties par le
secrétaire général des nations unies
monsieur kofi annan venu dans la région
pour calmer le jeu tenter notamment au
liban d'utiliser ses bons offices pour
négocier la libération des trois soldats
israéliens canapé par le hezbollah
libanais
appel à la retenue aussi de washington
madeleine albright le secrétaire d'état
américain au président arafat elles
demandent de prendre les mesures
nécessaires à arrêter de violence
destructrice et absurde aux israéliens
et de dominer leur ressentiment après
les violences faites à leurs soldats et
de mettre immédiatement fin à leur
action armée hong kong
instant bill clinton s'est exprimée sur
ce qui se passe en ce moment même proche
orient je condamne fermement le meurtre
de soldats israéliens la maladie le
président américain je demande aux deux
parties de redonner un cessez-le-feu
immédiat et de condamner tous les actes
de violence et tandis que l'on apprenait
ces événements en israël et à gaza au
yémen une explosion à bord d'un navire
de guerre américain faisait 4 morts et
10 disparus dans le port d'aden selon le
président yéménite est pas un acte
terroriste mais en revanche pour les
américains ce serait bien une action
délibérée mais pas de confirmation
officielle pour l'instant commentaires
étienne ménard
dans un hôpital de la ville d'aden ce
matin le président yéménite rend visite
aux marins du navire américain six morts
plusieurs disparus et donc 35 blessées
la plupart brûlé gravement dans
l'explosion qui s'est produite ce matin
et qui selon le ministère américain de
la défense portent tous les signes d'une
attaque terroriste
le us et skol que l'on voit ici quitté
son port d'attache était sur le point de
s'amarrer dans le port d'aden pour faire
le plein de carburant selon plusieurs
témoignages l'explosion s'est produite
lorsqu'un petit zodiac ne matic censé
guider le navire américain pour les
manoeuvres d'amarrage a percuté le
bateau de plein fouet provoquant un trou
de 6 à 12 mètres dans la coque
s'il s'agit d'un acte terroriste nous y
répondrons par des mesures appropriées
mais pour le moment il convient d'être
prudent
alors mission suicide dans un zodiac
bourrée d'explosifs les autorités
américaines ensemble à l'heure qu'il est
convaincu compte tenu de l'extrême
tension qui règne dans la région tous
les bâtiments américains sur place ont
été placées en état d' alerte maximale
etienne leenhardt on sait que bill
clinton souhaitez réussir la paix au
proche-orient avant la fin de son mandat
mais ce soir les etats-unis donnent
l'impression d'être impuissant
oui c'est sans doute l'une des journées
les plus frustrantes de la présidence de
bill clinton aujourd'hui vous l'avez dit
il vient de s'exprimer ici à la maison
blanche tentant de ramener le calme
c'est ce qu'il essaie de faire depuis
plusieurs jours au téléphone
manifestement il n'y est pas parvenu
sans doute d'abord parce que plus la
situation se complique sur le terrain
plus sa marge de manoeuvre diminuent
sans doute ensuite parce que le sommet
de cannes des vite vous savez au mois de
juillet dernier avait été un échec
relatif et que ni israéliens ni
palestiniens ne veulent revenir autour
d'une table si ce n'est pour avoir le 6
mai date s'ils n'ont pas la certitude de
pouvoir obtenir des résultats
extrêmement concret et puis vous le
savez nous sommes en campagne électorale
ici aux etats-unis et même si monsieur
clinton ne se représente pas et qu'il a
donc en quelque sorte les mains libres
pour tenter le tout pour le tout dans
les six derniers mois qui lui restent et
bien l'opinion publique américaine qui
est traditionnellement plutôt pro
israélienne et bien cette opinion pèse
sur le débat et sur le rôle d'arbitré
que voudrait pouvoir jouer le président
clinton jusqu'au bout de son mandat
merci etienne le président chirac a
déploré toutes les violences et demandé
instamment à chacune des parties de ne
rien faire qui porterait un coup
irrémédiable à la paix monsieur chirac a
exprimé sa vie inquiétude avant de
rejoindre le sommet européen le biarritz
cette escalade porte en elle un très
grand danger
skatar général des nations unies
monsieur kofi annan et dans la région
il est porteur des espoirs et des
attentes de la communauté internationale
la france
présidente de l'union européenne lui
apporte son entier soutien
la france demande à toutes les parties
d'écouter le message de paix de
tolérance de respect mutuel de monsieur
kofi annan
elle les appelle à stopper immédiatement
les violences
avant que ne soit atteint le point de
non retour
de même le premier ministre lionel
jospin demande et à yasser arafat ehud
barak avec la plus grande gravité
d'arrêter cet engrenage de la violence
déplore profondément
toutes les violences qui se passe
actuellement
et
pense qu'il est absolument indispensable
de ne pas laisser se poursuivre cet
engrenage c'est pourquoi avec la plus
grande gravité je demande aussi bien
yasser arafat à ehud barak
d'arrêter cet engrenage de la violence
de de parler aux uns et aux autres de se
parler
car
si la paix qui doit être notre
préoccupation commune et c'est sur la
paix qu'ils seront jugés en france des
édifices de la communauté juive ont
encore été les cibles d'attaqués
d'agressions au lendemain d'un incendie
de la synagogue de trappes dans les
yvelines des cocktails molotov ont
visité galope à creil à colombes mais
également à la seyne-sur-mer dans le var
commentaires loïc de la mornais avec
gilles mariner 30 octobre au parc puis
gentiment on se sauve voilà c'est un peu
sauvage cette mère de famille est venue
précipitamment récupérer ses enfants à
l'école vives de ménilmontant théâtre de
nouvelles scènes d'agression cet après
midi malgré les services de sécurité
interne à l'école des enfants ont été
insultés et une secrétaire molesté dans
sa voiture
aujourd'hui une agression avec des
bouteilles des jets de bouteilles d
coûte moins toujours un passement
plaisir une secrétaire qui s'est fait
que s'est fait insulter du bonhomme sur
la voiture en train de taper des
insultes et propos raciale première
cible des provocations les synagogues
dans ce centre communautaire de la seyne
sur mer victimes la nuit dernière d'une
attaque au cocktail molotov la peur et
l'appréhension gagner les responsables
je n'étais pas tranquille et hier toute
la journée je suis resté là à faire pour
pour à ses dires le vigile car je
présentais qu'il allait nous arriver
quelques phoques l'attaqué la plus
violente et celle de trappes mardi soir
où un incendie criminel a ravagé la
synagogue
d'autres incidents insultes ou graffitis
racistes se multiplient depuis quelques
jours à l'encontre de la communauté
juive jusque dans les universités où les
responsables des étudiants ne cachent
pas leur inquiétude tous les jours nous
sommes victimes de provocations
d'agression dans les universités
françaises encore ce matin à
l'université paris ii panthéon assas
encore à nice ou encore à lyon ou à
l'université paris 8 des drapeaux
israéliens sont brûlés des appels au
meurtre sont faits par l'extrême droite
qui récupère bien sûr cette situation au
delà des provocations de l'extrême
droite les élus locaux comme les
policiers des renseignements généraux
s'inquiète de cette montée de tension
entre les jeunes des communautés juive
et musulmane les derniers incidents de
ramallah ne sont pas fait pour les
rassurer
lionel jospin réagi à céder à ces
agressions nous ferons preuve de la
sévérité la plus grande à l'égard de
tous ceux qui pourraient perpétrer des
actes de violence et tenir des slogans
racistes ou antisémites propos tenus à
biarritz où se trouve le premier
ministre à marseille les responsables
des communautés religieuses notamment
juives et musulmanes lançait un appel à
la tolérance et au respect mutuel
chacune des communautés avaient pris les
devants pour maintenir un dialogue
depuis quelques jours voyez le reportage
de yannick aroussi benoît jourdan
marseille est une ville qui a toujours
vécu de la richesse de ses diverses
communautés elle est une ville où l'on
se regarde et on se parle c'est le
pasteur protestant qui lance un appel au
calme
au nom de tous les dignitaires religieux
qui depuis dix ans travaillent ensemble
pour l'harmonie entre communautés un
appel d'ailleurs préventif puisque pour
l'instant à marseille il n'y a eu aucun
incident des éléments incontrôlés ça
peut arriver n'importe où je veux dire
on est on est on est pas à l'abri de ce
genre de choses mais si on peut arriver
à désamorcer cette spirale de la
violence je pense qu'il faut le faire
qu'est ce qui s'est passé là-bas
satisfaire les médias comme un énorme
iphone
ça touche ça blesse mais on demande que
ça va changer
samedi dernier les pro palestiniens
occupés laquelle hier la communauté
musulmane à marseille c'est 180 mille
personnes mardi c'était au tour d'une
partie des soixante dix mille juifs de
la ville d'apporter son soutien à l'état
d'israël
céline est juive samiha musulmane ont
chacune participer à leur manifestation
leurs points de vue s'affrontent mais
elles restent amis a marseille des
communautés ont l'habitude de vivre
ensemble c'est normal qu'ils soient pour
le peuple palestinien
parce qu'ils sont musulmans moi je suis
pour le peuple israélien parce que je
suis juive mais quelque part on continue
à cohabiter il me semble que le point
commun c'est tout de même une volonté de
là une volonté de paix voilà seulement
la paix ça fait un moment qu'on en parle
et il ne faut pas qu'elle se fasse de
cette manière là aujourd'hui c'est plus
la paix c'est la guerre c'est dire les
seniors sont d'accord sur un point les
espère que là bas aussi un jour
musulmans et juifs pour marcher d'un
même pas en totale harmonie
monsieur jospin aux côtés du chef de
l'état depuis les représentants du
gouvernement participent à partir de
demain au sommet européen de biarritz un
sommet placé sous très haute
surveillance compte tenu des intentions
des indépendantistes basques espagnols
de s'inviter entre guillemets ou en
marge de ce sommet voyez le reportage de
pascal douce est bon et pascal cas
le sens des images côté espagnol les
nationalistes base que l'on t'a qui
depuis longtemps alors aujourd'hui pas
question pour eux de franchir la
frontière en ordre dispersé il faut
faire masse passe aux journalistes
cordialement invitées pour l'occasion
400 voitures sont ainsi arrivés
d'espagne aujourd'hui pourtant hier
encore la police aux frontières affiché
son intention de fil très attentivement
tous les points de passage elle a reçu
le renfort de crs et de gendarmes
mobiles est mis sur le terrain toutes
ses unités à commencer par les chiens
dressés à la recherche d'explosifs
terroristes et l'autre côté de la
frontière
pour éviter qu'il agit de ce côté ci il
ya des mouvements de violence urbaine de
la même façon c'est contre lecompte
tiers en
objectif de les entraver mais ce matin
les policiers se contentait de compter
les voitures trop de contrôles n'aurait
fait que jeter de l'huile sur le feu et
provoqué des embouteillages monstres
alors les manifestants ont librement
pris la route du nord mais arriver au
niveau de biarritz interdiction quitter
l'autoroute la ville est devenu un camp
retranché où l'on est prié de ne
circuler qu'à pied les militants basques
devront donc se contenter de bayonne ce
qui ne plaît pas du tout aux maires
il y as parmi tous ces jeunes qui
franchiront la frontière des jeunes qui
forment donc la guérilla urbaine
régulièrement à saint sébastien et
ailleurs et je peur que ils viennent
transformer bayonne n'est ce pas alain
carbou trancher avec des manifestations
violentes
et malgré la pluie le contre-sommet
comme ils disent a déjà commencé dans le
calme pour l'instant
les menaces d'actions de letea sont donc
prises très au sérieux en espagne comme
en france en moins de dix mois les
attentats imputés à eta ont fait
quatorze morts en espagne à chaque fois
des centaines de milliers de personnes
ont manifesté leur refus de la violence
en réaction la nièce vahramian est à la
fois hier ont recueilli des témoignages
de familles de victimes qui entendent
bien résisté au fanatisme de terrain
christina cuesta avait 20 ans quand son
père a été assassiné par eta dix huit
ans plus tard elle est une figure des
mouvements contre l'organisation armée
elle publie un premier livre de
témoignages de victimes de thé à un
premier alors que les séparatistes tu
depuis 40 ans
le problème de la violence terroriste
c'est que ça a été un tabou pendant
longtemps
on pour plusieurs raisons on a pensé que
t as étaient des combattants anti
franquiste qui n'a crû que l'arrivée de
la démocratie allait les faire réfléchir
et que parce que t as été basque nos
actions pouvaient bénéficiait tout ça
c'était beaucoup de mystification
sept affiches réclamant la paix contre
la violence n'est d'ailleurs pas
visibles sur les murs de san sebastien
couvert en revanche de graffitis protea
dans les rues seul ce monument censé
représenter une colombe rappelle les 800
victimes de l'organisation
il y a quelques semaines sept écrivains
basques signait le premier manifeste
d'intellectuels contre eta tardivement
la culture ici a toujours était
nationaliste mais cette fois que tu es à
la confisque
été assassinés au nom de la culture
basque au nom de la langue nous nous ne
nous sentons pas représentés par eta
crois que nous pouvons faire la culture
basque nous mêmes n'avons besoin de
personne pour la protéger on m'a dit ce
que nous avons à faire
à chaque mort de théa les pacifistes ont
instauré leurs rituels un quart d'heure
de silence devant les mairies sans autre
revendication sans slogans politiques
christina cuesta y retrouve une amie
maria sandrine députés à saint sébastien
du parti populaire la droite espagnole
elle est menacée de mort et vit comme
christina sous escorte policière
on a beaucoup d'années on a supporté le
manque de liberté on s'est dit beaucoup
de foi pour ne pas avoir des problèmes
on a eu beaucoup de peur et je crois que
sur le moment quand tout cela doit fini
christina cuesta et ses amis voudrait
que les bases que manifestent clairement
leur attachement à l'espagne mais dans
cette région autonome hou 50% des
habitants sont nationalistes brandir un
drapeau espagnol est encore une
provocation
la suite du mouvement de protestation
des gardiens de prison contre budget de
l'administration financière
manifestation rhône alpes ou en auvergne
toulouse à marseille totalement et puis
en région parisienne notamment à fresnes
où les extractions de détenus n'ont pu
se faire régulièrement les gardiens de
prisons réclament de meilleures
conditions de travail et des créations
d'emploi supplémentaires nous avons pu
nous rendre dans un centre de détention
modèle non loin de provins en
seine-et-marne villenauxe-la-grande pour
interroger gardien est responsable de ce
centre reportage à nice garde et alain
locascio
la relève les uns sont libérés les
autres prennent leur service marc va
passer huit heures derrière les barreaux
à ouvrir et fermer les cellules le
métier peut paraître ingrat et pourtant
les satisfactions existent
et vous me connaissez par coeur
le découpe savoir qu'à
5 heures du matin et le monde et je sais
qui vaut qu'ils ouvrent la porte quelle
surveillance
mais pas être réduit pour autant être de
simples porte-clés voilà ce que les
surveillants demandent sans participer
aux manifestations
marc se sent solidaire de ses collègues
grévistes ici dans cet établissement
récente on enferme jusqu'à 400 détenus
400 détenus pour 105 surveillante
troupes le disent les personnel
insuffisant en tout cas pour mener à
bien l'ensemble de leurs missions
forcément les écoute cheikh tall écoute
toujours les coudes car soissons 1 4
toujours
pas toujours
et la base n'est pas la seule à soulever
les mêmes problèmes le directeur attend
depuis trois mois anne adjoint pour le
seconde et il ne voit rien venir
aujourd'hui on nous demande de faire de
la réinsertion nous sommes favorables à
cette mission mais à une condition c'est
qu'on puisse la faire sereinement qu'on
nous donne du personnel administratif
qu'on nous donne du personnel de
surveillance comme au temps du personnel
de direction et du personnel si c'était
leur service socio-éducatif
le manque d'effectif ce n'est pas tout
les gardiens de prison qui gagnent en
moyenne 8000 francs par mois réclament
une hausse de salaire de mars la
direction de l'administration
pénitentiaire doit leur faire des
propositions concrètes pour sortir du
conflit
plus d'un mois après l'accident de métro
survenu à la station notre dame de
lorette à paris un premier rapport
confirme une vitesse excessive de 62 km
heure au lieu de trente deux fois plus
l'accident avait fait 24 blessés légers
la direction de la ratp annonce la mise
en place de balises pour désormais mieux
contrôler la vitesse des trains petit à
petit les tarés forme sa gestion et
tente d'alléger quelques procédures
quelques paperasse le ministre fonction
publique michel sapin annonçait ce matin
la fin des fiches d'état civil et des
justificatifs de domicile portage sophie
mais elle et cédric picot
aujourd'hui le quotidien d'un bureau
d'état civil ça ressemble à peu près à
ça des centaines de démarches
administratives qui une fois sur deux se
résume à la délivrance d'une fiche
d'état civil en presque 50 ans
d'existence ce document a su se rendre
indispensable pour une multitude de
démarches sécurité sociale caisse
d'allocations familiales de retraite
inscriptions scolaires demande de
logement et j'en oublie
vous avez besoin pour quel usage
remplir un dossier pour passer des
examens et vous l'avez demandé combien
cette année seuls
très longtemps j'en redemande et là je
pense à très très rare quand jean monnet
et pourtant 60 millions d'exemplaires
sont délivrés chaque année par les
mairies en moyenne une fiche par an et
par habitant mais dès le premier
laissant tout ça ce sera oublié plus de
démarches superflu à la mairie il
suffira de présenter à l'administration
concernée carte d'identité passeport ou
livret de famille voire même simplement
une photocopie certifiée conforme par
l'usager en clair l'administration a
décidé de faire confiance ou simples
citoyens
si on commence à traiter les gens à
partir de quelques fraudeurs on applique
des procédures très lourdes à tout le
monde alors que ces procédures sont à
peine efficace par rapport à
quelques-uns bientôt le personnel des
mairies sera donc beaucoup moins
bousculés
il en profitera c'est sûr pour consacrer
beaucoup plus de temps à chaque usager
l'adoption l'assemblée nationale d'une
proposition de loi socialiste visant à
lutter plus efficacement contre les
discriminations au travail ce texte
devrait permettre à un salarié de ne
plus être écartée d'une procédure de
recrutement ou bien être licencié pour
des raisons d'origine d'opinion de vie
sexuelle ou encore d'apparence physique
derniers jours au rpr pour l'adhérent
jean tiberi le maire de paris persiste à
vouloir se présenter aux prochaines
municipales sera officiellement exclu du
mouvement gaulliste ce soir par le
comité départemental de la fédération
père de paris ce matin dans le journal
le parisien monsieur tiberi parlait de
nouveau un rôle de bouc émissaire
reportage laurent hakim syrie le pâquier
la semaine des fausses notes pour jean
tiberi les hlm le crédit municipal et
maintenant l'exclusion du rpr à quelques
heures de la sentence le maire de paris
ne mâche pas ses mots certains qui se
disent à mes amis
cela une mauvaise action je n'ai
simplement s'ils le font quant à jean
tiberi reste candidat la saga parisienne
entre donc dans son seizième mois
17 juin 99 la bataille s'engage le rpr
ne veut pas d'un candidat engluée dans
les affaires jean tiberi prend tout le
monde de vitesse
vous saviez depuis longtemps
la havane soir dans l'intérêt de paris
et dans l'union j'ai la confiance de
jacques chirac dit souvent jean tiberi
mais l'attitude du président reste en
vie des
2 février 2000 les troupes tibet rist
sont sur le pont aujourd'hui certains
sont devenus séguiniste de son québec
d'adoption philippe séguin envisage
sérieusement d'être le candidat officiel
15 mars première sommation première
suspension ribéry ne dirigera plus la
fédération rpr de paris première menace
ne continuez pas dans cette voie ou
alors c'est que vous avez tiré un trait
sur les municipales les législatives et
les présidentielles
23 mai le combattant séguin remportent
le grand oral des prétendants de la
droite quelques jours plus tard la
comédie parisienne s'offrent la scène
d'un théâtre
j'ai été le bouc émissaire j'ai été
livré aux chiens moi aussi et l'on a
joué avec l'honneur et la dignité
26 septembre dernier avertissement jean
tiberi est suspendu du rpr la présidente
de la fédération parisienne nicole
cathala a donc tranché ça serait une
suspension dit-elle conservatoire
mesdames messieurs de qui se moque t'on
depuis le début de la crise candidats
officiels et candidats dissidents ne se
sont croisés que dans les stades de
football faute de rencontre la rupture
est consommée et il y a toujours deux
candidats de la droite à la mairie de
paris j'évite imbert à la fédération rpr
de paris l'exclusion de jean tiberi est
en cours oui en fait tout est en train
de se passer dans cette grande salle qui
est en fête loué par le rpr parisien
pour l'occasion jean tiberi est arrivé
ici vous allez le voir peu après 20
heures dans une cohue indescriptible
un jean tiberi bien décidé à se dresser
énergiquement physiquement prêt ce que
j'allais dire par sa présence contre la
décision qui va donc le frapper ce soir
car évidemment il n'y a pas beaucoup de
suspense en ce moment nicole cathala
caila président du rpr parisien a
prononcé un rapport qui est en fait un
véritable réquisitoire contre le maire
un rapport qui devrait conduire la
majorité des quelques 300 délégués du
rpr parisien a prononcé donc la sanction
suprême c'est à dire l'exclusion de jean
tiberi même même si l'exclusion
officielle définitive elle ne sera
prononcée que le 24 octobre par le rpr
nationale par michèle alliot marie cette
fois le 24 octobre le lan le 25 jean
tiberi tient son premier grand meeting
de campagne la preuve s'il en fallait
une qu'il reste même exclu dans la
course à sa succession jamais merci jeff
pour la première fois une ministre du
gouvernement jospin madame monet met en
cause directement de monsieur chirac
dans la firme irie celle des hlm de la
ville de paris madame voynet critique la
réserve de sa collègue elisabeth guigou
estime que monsieur chirac doit
s'expliquer devant la justice la dignité
de l'homme la crédibilité de sa fonction
l'imposent fin de citation des propos de
madame voynet je vous ai indiqué hier
que les cotations boursières étaient
très sérieusement la base qu'elle avait
même rejoint le niveau 2 des 199 sous
les 6000 points pour le cac 40
aujourd'hui paris a repris un petit peu
de terrain comme on dit mais la tendance
reste toujours négative les
investisseurs sont prudents ils se
moquent méfie beaucoup des valeurs de
nouvelles technologies récit david beeri
avec dernière puissesseau
en haut le nasdaq à new york en bas la
bourse de paris la courbe du cac 40 se
calque minute par minute sur la tendance
américaine et la tendance est
franchement à la baisse -15 % à paris en
un mois
l'année 2000 avait pourtant commencé par
une succession de records le 4 septembre
dernier le cac 40 est au plus haut mais
depuis c'est le plongeon retour à la
case départ l' indice parisien est passé
en dessous de la barre symbolique des
6000 points le mouvement vient bien des
états unis à wall street les plus
grandes entreprises sont en train de
revoir à la baisse leurs prévisions de
résultats l'eldorado de la nouvelle
économie ne tient pas toutes ses
promesses
aujourd'hui il ya des signes de léger
ralentissement mais c'est un léger
ralentissement qui fait s'interroger les
marchés et si le ralentissement était
plus violents qu'est ce que ça va donner
on ne sait pas répondre à cette question
là donc les investisseurs deviennent
prudent et s'allège d'une partie de leur
portefeuille il s'allège surtout en
vendant des actions du secteur des
télécoms un secteur très endetté les
opérateurs ont emprunté cette année 1300
milliards de francs presqu'autant que le
budget de l'état pour financer la
nouvelle génération de portables la
facture est déjà très lourde pour de
nouveaux services qui ne seront pas
rentable avant longtemps
les éleveurs de montagne ont manifesté
aujourd'hui dans plusieurs massifs
français pour protester contre un projet
de réforme de leurs primes
compensatoires
projet imposé par bruxelles
rassemblement à pomezia grenoble et dans
les vosges les éleveurs du massif
central se sont trouvés dans le cantal
il est est aujourd'hui à aurillac où se
trouvait pour france 2 eric masi et
nathalie gallet
chaque matin on allons nourrir les bêtes
marie-jeanne entend le ruisseau les
cloches des petits riens pour se dire
que sa vie à la montagne est agréable
même si le travail parfois la submerge
l'hiver est long l'exploitation peu
mécanisée alors 130 animaux c'est
beaucoup quand on dit que tous les deux
à travailler on a un fils de 29 ans le
travail ailleurs parce que sur cette
exploitation
c'est vrai que des fois c'est
décourageant parce que on a beaucoup de
travail on n'est pas rémunéré en
conséquence
avec 4000 autres éleveurs elle s'est
rendue au pied du plomb du cantal déjà
engagé une transhumance humaine pour
protester contre la réforme de la
politique l'aide accordée aux zones de
montagne
grâce à cette politique
170 jeunes l'an dernier nous avons
invalides ou tort sur deux
niveaux c'est la fin de la vente à
hisser h l indemnité compensatrice des
handicaps naturels c'est ce que veulent
sauver des agriculteurs il aurait
préféré écrire le mot montagne mais il
fallait être plus nombreux la réforme
prévoit de diminuer les primes aux
exploitations ayant trop d'animaux à
l'hectare pour bruxelles il s'agit de
transformer des aides économiques en
subventions pour l'environnement
tiennent compte de l'environnement nous
sommes d'accord et l agriculteur de
mental pour être content puisqu'ils font
de l'environnement déjà depuis très
nombreuses années mais c'est un ace que
pour nous que ce soit l'élément
principal d'une définition de politiques
davantage
à quelques jours des prochaines
discussions avec le ministre de
l'agriculture luc guyau a donc réussi à
mobiliser ses troupes de façon pacifique
sport cyclisme au championnat du monde
de plouay dans le morbihan c'est un
ukrainien sergeï gonchar qui est à
remporter le titre mais grands
spécialistes étaient absents et le
français laurent jalabert avait déclaré
forfait il était souffrant
le prix nobel de littérature 2011
récompense un écrivain de langue
chinoise gao xing zhang âgé de 60 ans il
est citoyen français depuis trois ans
romancier dramaturge son oeuvre
principale certitude la montagne de
l'âme ses oeuvres sont toujours
interdites en chine portrait de gao xin
zhang par michel sous l'eau viciée
christ vignal
grande chance elle prend l'avancé
c'est par ces mots simples que le grand
écrivain gaouzi young exprime sa joie il
est le premier chinois à obtenir le
nobel de littérature depuis la création
du prix en 1901 c'est dire toute
l'importance de cet auteur réfugié en
france depuis 1988
créateurs aux talents multiples
romancier bien sûr mais aussi dramaturge
traducteur cali grâce et peintre gao xin
zhang est un lit très moderne amoureux
de la littérature française
contemporaine
il a su concilier comme personne la
manière occidentale d'écrire et les
préoccupations de son peuple dans ce
siècle agitée
pendant la révolution culturelle comme
des millions de chinois il est victime
de la terreur ordonnée par mao gao xin
zhang sera interné six ans durant dans
un camp de travail à la campagne ces
drames vont le marquer à jamais mais il
refuse de se taire et d'accepter le
dicta culturelle des autorités de pékin
ses oeuvres sont censurés gao ying yang
est un précurseur de la révolte
étudiante de la place tiananmen
s'est réfugié à paris qu'il pourra
exprimer tous ces talents et explorer de
nouvelles manières de créer sans oublier
ses racines dans la tradition en poche
on pas assimiler des
sables
range entre et créativité
la tradition comprend pas tout en
s'inspirant de la culture chinoise zhao
jing zhang c'est nous parler de
l'universel
nous arrivons à la fin de cette édition
je rappelle l'actualité au proche orient
un véritable état de guerre entre israël
et les palestiniens trois militaires
israéliens ont été lynchées à mort
défenestré dans un commissariat de
police à ramallah aussitôt israël a
riposté il y avait eu plusieurs raids
israéliens pas ces images que vous voyez
images tournées par thil jeune italienne
rade israéliens ont été menées sur
ramallah sur des sites abritant la
direction l'autorité palestinienne il y
aurait 36 palestiniens blessés au cours
de ces raids à son tour le hamas
islamique a menacé puis ce soir le fatah
le mouvement du président elias et rafat
a décrété une mobilisation dans ses
rangs trop faire face à je cite
l'agression israélienne affirmant
qu'elle ne l'année serait pas sans
riposte les etats unis la france ont
lancé les appels pour sauver la paix et
arrêter cet engrenage dans quelques
instants la météo avec sophie davant
suivi du point route avec valérie
maurice à 20h50 envoyé spécial qui vous
sera présenté par bernard benyamin avec
notamment une enquête dès la marque ou
sur des femmes violées à 1h15 le journal
de la nuit sera présentée par laurence
piquet demain 7h 50 dans les 4 vérités
gérard morin recevra en duplex de
jérusalem avi pazner qui est le porte
parole du gouvernement israélien à 13h
retrouvez gérard holtz et puis demain
dans l'édition de 20 heures présenté
bien sûr par béatrice schönberg nous
proposerons une émission spéciale en
direct le 2 jérusalem bonsoir merci